here's the hard truth about getting
great you've got two choices in life
choice one you can become somebody else
choice - you can become yourself so many
people are obsessed with becoming
perfect that they never take action and
they never learn to enjoy this moment
that may be one of the greatest
tragedies any of us can face wanna soar
get a mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's learn from one
of the best Tom Bill you and let's get
inspired by some of his best
motivational speeches mentor me Tom
okay let's kick it off with speech
number one continue to push here's the
hard truth about getting great it takes
time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good enough it takes the ability to
stare at the places that you know that
you're weak to really look at those
things and not let it affect your sense
of self-esteem and not let it affect
your sense of self-worth so that you can
still get the momentum going but you
have to understand that in the beginning
we're all terrible and as Henri
cartier-bresson said your first 10,000
photographs are your worst and so the
thing that really makes great art are
the people that continue to push and the
people that continue to work and face
how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
over time going out every day on the
fraid of whether or not this is one of
the 10,000 terrible things that you're
gonna do it's being unafraid to make
those mistakes it's being unafraid that
you're not yet great and as Marianne rad
maker said courage doesn't always war
sometimes courage is the quiet voice at
the end of the day saying I will try
again tomorrow and that's it if you want
to be great that's what you have to do
you've got to get up again tomorrow
you've got to be willing to face another
day you've got to be willing to accept
that you've got to get through the bad
ideas before you can get to the good
you've got to understand that you have
to start as an apprentice you have to
start as a person going and getting tea
and you have to accept that that's the
job that you should be playing that you
should be working for somebody else you
should be looking up to somebody else's
seeing what they can teach you because
what you know is that you're there to
learn
you're there to get through the 10,000
bad photographs you need to get through
to ultimately achieve greatness and if
you make the catastrophic error that's
so many made to try to tell the world of
your extraordinary today to try to get
the world to follow you and look up to
you and Fifi or something today because
the people that live in win
the ones that listen today the ones that
spend every ounce of their energy
amassing mastery getting better every
day working their asses off to food
their skillset to relentlessly look at
the things that they're not doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really find
greatness those are the people that we
remember so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day and take another swing
take another photo
try another task do something that
scares you and do those little things
over and over and over until you win
speech number two change your attitude
as Maya Angelou said if you don't like
something change it if you can't change
it change your attitude that's some of
the best advice you're ever going to
hear at the end of the day you should
always be trying to change the things
that you have the ability to change
there are inevitably going to be things
that you can't change but you're never
helpless you're never a victim in that
moment you still have the unbelievable
ability to choose to look at it in a new
way to choose to reframe it and in that
reframing you change everything you
don't just change your own neural
chemistry you're not just changing the
way that you feel you're actually
changing the way that your going to
approach the problem something that was
moments before something that seemed
impossible something that was breaking
your will to continue to fight with a
change in attitude becomes something
completely different and as hans selye
said adopting the right attitude can
turn a negative stress into a positive
one and that game of mental jujitsu is
what it's about that game of flipping
something on its head of turning
something around of seeing it in a new
way so that you can act in a new way is
how you make forward progress and
understanding that understanding the
need to take control of your perceptions
understanding that understanding your
need to change your perspective that's
how you begin to get ahead once you
understand your perspective is a choice
it is not objective truth burn that into
your mind it is not objective truth the
world that you see around you is simply
the perspective through which you see it
all of life is a funhouse mirror
and when you acknowledge that when you
understand that you're looking at a
distorted view of the way the world is
you realize that you can adopt a
different Distortion you can adopt a
diss or see things more clearly that
allow you to see things in a way that
empower you and that should always be
the first step is figuring out not what
is not what you can change but instead
understanding what you need to change it
to an understanding that that change
comes from inside you it isn't a
manifestation that you have to make in
the outside world for us it's a change
you have to make inside yourself it is a
shift of perspective it is simply
stepping to the side of what you're used
to and how you use the seeing things and
understanding that in reframing things
you take that negative and turn it into
something that builds you up but you've
got to choose you've got to decide
you've got to believe that you can do it
but once you believe that you can see
things in any way that you need to to
reach your goals your life will change
forever
because you'll actually reach your goals
speech number three be yourself you've
got two choices in life choice one you
can become somebody else choice - you
can become yourself now I really wish
that there was only one choice but in
truth there's not in most people shoes
to try to become someone else because
it's a road map its points in the
direction you see someone you respond to
something you admire them you want to be
like them and in that process you've
made your decision in that process you
decided to become somebody else you have
mistaken the finger for the moon instead
you need to understand them being
inspired by somebody does not mean to
become that person to become that which
inspires you it is to understand
fundamentally what is it about that
thing that excites you what is it
essence and when you can find its
essence then you can find out how it
would apply to you becoming you and as
Zen she says flower does not think about
competing with the flower next to it it
just blooms and that's really your job
is to see the outside world to see the
flower next to you to understand the
amazing things that are happening all
around you all of the incredible people
and the essence of what they have and
what it is that they've done to bring
inside yourself and find out what does
that look like when it's me not what do
I look like when I'm them and once you
understand the difference between that
then you can really begin to be
something unique you can become that
thing that you were meant to be that
thing that makes you feel alive and
whole and that's it that's the secret
you're just trying to be something not
that's just inspiring to other people if
you actually want to wake up every day
and be and that's the [ __ ] thing
about it
so escaping you whenever you become a
lie the truth somebody else yourself
whatever it is
every day
you are lighted there and his Albert
Einstein said everybody is a genius but
if you judge a fish by its ability to
climb a tree it will live it's whole
life believing that it's stupid and
that's what confuses people
[Music]
they're done because they're not finding
their have they're not defining things
based on what excites them and what they
want to live with
they're just looking to what the outside
world says is good and I think it's
incredible if there are other people
doing things that are so extraordinary
that we aspire to be like that but you
have to understand the difference
between being like someone and trying to
actually be speech number four
don't let obstacles break you as
Confucius said when it's obvious that
the goal cannot be reached don't adjust
the goals adjust the action steps that
may be the single best piece of advice
you're ever going to get write that down
burn it into your flesh tattoo it on
your soul do whatever you need to do to
remember that once you set a goal once
you've decided in your life there is
something that you're going to make come
true don't let anything stop you from
reaching that but the reality is is you
go things are gonna get in your way
there will be an inevitable slew of
obstacles coming at you but when it gets
so hard that you realize that the path
that you're on is simply not going to
take you where you want to go rather
than give up on what it was you said you
were gonna do find a different path and
in that when you really make that the
cornerstone of your identity that you
refuse to bend or be broken by obstacles
by challenges but instead you rise to
those challenges you go over under
through them you do whatever you have to
you devise any plan to find a way
through then your life will change once
that becomes your reaction to not change
that thing that meant so much to you
you've dedicated your life to making it
come true that you don't change that but
rather you find another way you tap into
your creativity you find somebody that
can help you you do whatever it takes to
get on the other side of that you do
whatever it takes to build that life
that you want to see but if your
reaction is to change your goal
to make it easier to move it closer to
be less of who you could be simply so
you can check a box you're never gonna
have anything that's worth having also
if you want to have more confidence in
self-love checking my 254 series they're
free the links to join are in the
description but there's a gap between
who people are and what they tell you
they want to accomplish you can tell the
world to eat less and exercise more and
it will work for every single person
ever that's ever done it but the reality
is the vast majority the world will not
do that what you think about yourself is
at the end of the day the single most
important thing speech number 5 get
started
as Haroon 'yeah noted i always wonder
why birds stay in the same place when
they can fly anywhere on earth and then
i ask myself the same question as mark
twain put it the secret of getting ahead
is getting started and that's where
people get stuck you're literally like
the bird you could fly anywhere you want
you can go anywhere you want to go and
look I know you've got a litany of
excuses and all of them are valid you've
got a job you can't just leave when you
don't have a job and you don't have the
money your family is in one place it's
the only thing that you've ever known
you only speak one language you've never
traveled before you don't have a
passport you can't afford the gas money
there are a thousand real reasons not to
go but the truth is that none of them
matter the truth is if you want to build
something in your life that you have to
remember what Mark Twain said you have
to get started because at the end of the
day that is literally the only thing
that's holding you back
you're not moving and once you get the
simplicity of that once you understand
that you could act right now you could
say
all the excuses you can't stop making
them you can stop giving in to them no
matter how valid they are no matter how
real they may seem you can finally
decide that you're going to get a movie
you're going to create that momentum
that you're going to take a step that
you're gonna make the demand that you
create momentum that you get something
done that you find an answer or as
Hannibal said that you're going to find
a way or make one if you have to carve
through the rock do it because humans
before you
and that's the simple truth that is the
simple everything else is the weak voice
in your mind holding you back and making
you a less version of yourself so I
asked you why doesn't the bird fly
wherever it wants to go because that's
all it's known because that's what's
safe because that's what's comfortable
well because it's a dumb an animal what
do you want to be if this isn't the life
you want to live do something about it
speech number six focus on the adventure
as Ralph Waldo Emerson said we're all
inventors each sailing out on a voyage
of discovery guided each by a private
chart of which there is no duplicate
we're all lost at sea we're all on this
grand adventure but the punchline is we
have no idea where we're going and the
map that we have is private only to us
and it's quite frankly blank and it's
about filling it in it's about learning
where you are it's about finding
guideposts and beginning to build this
map only from that which you've done and
so you have to go blindly forward and
the only thing that's going to give you
the courage to step into that abyss to
step into the truly unknown into the
dangerous world before you truly into a
sea of infinite peril
the only thing that's going to give you
the courage to do that is that you can
learn that you'll figure it out it's not
going to be easy it's going to be hard
and at times it is truly going to be
life-threatening but that is the nature
of life
and as you're out there in the
wilderness as you're out there lost at
sea all you have to do is remember two
things it is an adventure an adventures
are never safe but the rewards of an
adventure or the discovery of something
entirely new and two you can do it you
can do it the very fact that you're a
human gives you the ability to process
your surroundings to figure things out
to go in and fumble around you're not
going to look good you're going to drink
a ton of ocean water and it is going to
suck and you're gonna be vomiting over
the sides and this is going to be
difficult there are going to be times
when you're convinced you're going to
drown but if in those moments you stay
clear-headed and you focus on getting
better you focus on the adventure you
don't worry about the outcome you just
focus on right now in this moment with
everything going wrong what can I learn
to calm yourself and to remember right
there if you're panicking you're asking
the wrong question if you're panicking
you're asking questions about how you
look you're asking questions about how
this is going to end up if you want to
kill your panic in any moment ask
yourself right then and there what can I
learn what can I learn from this life is
nothing to practice and as long as you
keep that in mind as long as you
understand it's never performance it's
always this is simply an opportunity to
learn and get better then you can
reframe the entire ordeal that you're
going through and as Paulo Coelho said
people are capable at any time in their
lives of doing what they dream of but
it's only going to come true through
that process of learning and discovery
and putting yourself out there and going
into the unknown but if you're never
willing to step off because all you can
see are the problems all you can see are
the things that could go wrong and you
never get the chance to learn but the
way that humans learn is truth
engagement is through interacting and if
you don't dare to do that if you don't
dare to step out into the unknown and to
flounder around and look stupid and
embarrass yourself then you're never
gonna grow it if you never grow then
you're never going to make your dreams
come true so if you have that dream
locked inside of you know that the only
way to get it out is to risk to dare to
strive to try to grow to grow to fall to
fail
to learn and ultimately succeed that's
the only way that dreams come true
speech number seven use your potential
as Buckminster Fuller said there's
nothing in a caterpillar that tells you
that it's going to be a butterfly and
welcome to the human condition that's
the truth of what it's like to be a
person you're hoping that you turn
inward and see some sign some glimmer
some gift that you have that's been
bestowed upon you that you were born
with that is your very birthright but
there's nothing you were born hopelessly
average and the sooner that you accept
that the sooner that you accept that you
were no better than anyone that came
before you and everyone that's going to
come after you but all of us have
potential and so the question becomes
the question you have to answer with
your very life the question that your
actions will answer what are you gonna
do with that potential will you actuate
it will you bust your ass to get good
will you get so good over time that you
can play with the greats will you get so
good that people look at you with awe
can you get so good that you become the
excuse that other people use not to try
can you get so good that people have to
dismiss you as naturally talented can
you get so good the people refuse to
believe that they
get that good can you work so hard
gaining a set of skills and driving
yourself day after day to get better
never accepting who you are always
pushing yourself forward always
demanding more and seeing the beauty in
what you can become and knowing that
even today as a caterpillar with nothing
with nothing to indicate you'll become a
butterfly can you become the butterfly
do sheer force of will because if you
can become that you become a beacon of
hope not for other people for yourself
because you prove that there really are
no limits and as well businesses may not
realize it when it happens but a kick in
the teeth may be the best thing in the
world for you why because it's the thing
that's going to make you react it's the
thing that's gonna hold you down it's
the thing that is going to make you say
never again
no more I refuse to accept this about
myself I refuse to accept that I'm
average I refuse to accept that I can't
be something more I refuse to stop when
something kicks me in the teeth I refuse
to stop when people hate on me or tell
me that I can't do something I refuse to
be dictated to by anyone even my own
potential I refuse to be held back by
anything least of all me speech number 8
don't chase perfection so many people
are obsessed with becoming perfect that
they never take action and they never
learn to enjoy this moment that may be
one of the greatest tragedies any of us
can face that right now whatever we are
however we are however good we are
whatever we've accomplished that we fail
to enjoy this moment because we have a
judgement about who we are deep down
because we haven't acted in a way that's
perfect and I get it we have this drive
it's innate in us we want to be great
it's one of the five primary human
drivers to pursue mastery to want to
master something and truly be
extraordinary I understand the drive but
don't let it corrode you don't ever do
something that eats you alive from the
inside you've got to have a vision of
yourself that allows you to morph and
change and learn from your mistakes but
if you value perfection over learning
then you're never gonna become the
person that you'd be capable of becoming
and as Anna Quindlen said the thing that
is really hard and really amazing is
giving up on being perfect and beginning
the work of becoming yourself speech
number nine enjoy the moment as Martin
Luther said even if I knew that tomorrow
the world would go to pieces I would
still plant my apple tree some things
you build whether you can control the
outcome or not sometimes it's the
process that is the thing that's meant
to be enjoyed it's the process that
you're meant to invest in and rather
than always thinking about the goal the
outcome or what you're going to get out
of something focus on to something focus
on the part of it that you can control
because you can't always control the
outcome you can't know what's gonna
happen tomorrow tomorrow's not
guaranteed to any of us and yet we all
act and yet we create momentum in our
lives when we're at our best but we do
that not because we can control every
aspect we do that because we accept that
there are things that we cannot control
and as steve maraboli said incredible
change happens in your life when you
decide to take control of what you do
have power over instead of craving
control over what you don't and that's
where a lot of people get lost
they focus not on what they have in
their hands they focus instead on the
things that they can't control it
irritates them it frustrates them it's
like a splinter in their mind they can't
stop thinking about the things that they
don't have control over and they're
blinded to the incredible wealth that is
around them of things that they could
enjoy right here right now
that's why gratitude is such an
empowering practice to sit there and not
think of the glorious things may await
you in your future but rather to think
about the things that you have here in
this moment oxygen in your lungs a
simple breeze on your face a window in
your house someone that you love someone
that loves you nothing that costs money
nothing that was the pot of gold at the
end of a glorious rainbow it's not even
about becoming something extraordinary
and waiting for the results of that it's
simply understanding that the one thing
you can control are your actions today
the choices that you make
you get to do how you think about
yourself the beliefs you choose to bring
into your life those things you control
and when you understand the power in
acknowledging that control and taking
control and using it that's when your
life is going to beginning to change but
first you have to divorce yourself from
being obsessively interested only in an
outcome if instead you build your
self-esteem you build your pride on
pursuit you build your pride and
allowing yourself to care about
something so deeply that even though
tomorrow is not guaranteed that you're
going to plant your apple tree today
that you're going to love that process
because it is the thing that you can
control you can control how you show up
you can control how you play you cannot
control how other people react you
cannot control what they think about you
but you can control what you think about
yourself you can earn credibility with
yourself you can control what you do and
when you take full ownership of that and
realize that your life is an exact
reflection of the core choices of the
things you could control and what you do
with them then everything begins to
change you're not looking to blame
somebody else you're not even worried
anybody else you're just asking one
simple question
what can I do right now regardless of
tomorrow to improve my life
focus there and you'll enjoy every day
of your life and speech number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
speech is allow yourself to dream never
give up on what you really want to do
the person with big dreams is more
powerful than the person with all the
facts H Jackson Browne
truer words have never been spoken it is
one of the most interesting things about
the human condition that all of the
facts in the world no matter how true
something may objectively really be the
only thing that matters is whether or
not you've got the energy to see through
to the end of what you want to do and
the energy comes not from truth the
energy comes from your dream the energy
comes from what it is that you want to
do the energy ultimately is born out of
what you want to create it's born out of
a willingness to allow yourself to dream
it's born out of a willingness to think
that you actually can do it it's born
out of a willingness to take that first
step but the only reason that you're
gonna take that first step is you
believe that you can actually make your
dreams come true and that sense of this
thing that you have in your mind that
you can make it real that you can bring
it into the real world and have that
excitement you've long fantasized about
and understand and really feel in your
gut that that thing that you've dreamed
about can be real and when you have that
that's when you're going to have the
energy that you need to push and to
fight and to go through all of the
difficult things you're gonna have to to
get on the other side and make
dream meal as Ferdinand Fox said the
most powerful weapon on earth is the
human soul on fire but the human soul
can't be on fire without a dream a human
soul is not fed by facts a human soul is
fed instead by a belief that it can
accomplish what it wants to accomplish
it's fed by that thing that idea that
you've had in your mind that you fan
those flames of interest and turned it
into a real fascination and fan those
flames further into excitement and
allowed yourself to truly embody that
belief then you can make it happen so
right now whatever it is whatever crazy
dream you're having we all have one stop
judging yourself for it stop telling
yourself that you can't do it and
understand when you cultivate that fire
when you take that little Ember
and into a raging in front of the that
thing that human stole on fire
is what's going to allow you to build
something that the world has never seen
before but it starts for that dream it
starts with your willingness to
cultivate that - think about it - allow
yourself to do that because so many
people stop themselves they think
they're an atta fit they think that they
can never do it it's not something
that's gonna help you live a life that
excites you it's not something that's
gonna help you excite other people the
one thing that will do that is the dream
so right now allow yourself that simply
to dream now I have a special bonus
speech from Tom on how to build the life
that you want that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what do you just need to get started on
number two what's the attitude change
that you need to make and number three
what obstacle in front of you will you
refuse to let break you know if you
promise to take action after watching
this video give me a hash tag believe in
the comments to make it official I don't
think people really realize we construct
our lives we build them from nothing we
decide what our goals are we decide and
what way to move we decide who we're
going to become and what we're going to
get but it's a decision it's a process
it isn't something that somebody hands
to you and so if you find that your life
is a misery understand that your life is
an exact reflection of your choices and
if you want a different life you need to
only make a different choice but I know
right now many of you are thinking but I
don't know what way to go I don't know
what choice to make I don't know what it
is that I want to
and as ROI Maurice Keene said I don't
believe skill was or ever will be the
result of coaches it is a result of a
love affair between the child and the
ball so ask yourself what's that thing
that you love and don't judge yourself
if it was something that you loved as a
child that people are telling you you
couldn't possibly make money and it's
that part of the equation that I want to
break for people I want you to
understand
stop asking yourself what you can make a
lot of money yet and start asking
yourself what would you enjoy what is
that life that you don't need to escape
from what is the life that is your love
what is the thing that as a kid you did
whether people wanted you to or not what
is the thing you would seek out that
night to do because you weren't gonna be
stopped from doing it everybody has
something like that in their life some
spark of interest maybe long-dormant
maybe that they've pushed aside because
they think it's stupid or maybe they
failed once and they think they're bad
at it even though they love it that
sting of the failure has convinced them
to stop pursuing him
what gives you that energy the end of
the day thing that matters is what fills
you with joy at the end of the day the
only thing that matters it's not success
and sure as hell isn't money
you feel about yourself Levi
if the things that give you energy it's
what you think about yourself it's how
you react to the hard things whether or
not be pushed through and when you push
through when you persevere when you go
down the process of taking the time to
structure your life to build it into
something that you want it to be to
build it into something that you're
proud of to become the person that's
capable of the things you want to do
that can first fall in love with
something and do it for the love of it
and not worry about what other people
think if you hate your life I guarantee
you the thing is that you were trapped
by what other people think you don't
want to give it up because somebody will
think you're a failure you don't want to
give it up because it's a paycheck you
don't want to give it up because you're
scared you're scared you don't know what
you'll do next but imagine a world for a
second well all you thought about was
what do you love what do you enjoy in
that moment it doesn't matter if it
changes from day to day just what do you
love what fills you with joy what gives
you that energy at the end of the day
the only thing that we all have is right
now this moment it's what you're
experiencing loving what you do how you
spend your time that's the point of all
of it
the point of life is that in each
transient moment that passes by doing
something that fills you with joy nobody
can give you that
we've got to build that life so go out
figure out what it is that you want to
do and brick-by-brick have the courage
to build that life
if you want to watch the one-on-one
interview I did with Tom bill you
checked the video right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there our goal
is to build a studio that rivals Disney
so the reason that we want to do that
and the reason that is so tied to
entrepreneurs for me is that I believe